you know the planks it's shaken but it's
pretty quiet
there's no secretly throwing up it's all
a young like wow you're gonna be like
well like several people did get sick
including the people to the right in the
front row they were just that one person
was just ralphing and the dude sitting
next to the redheaded guy you said who I
said look like Justin Timberlake he was
like he was looking over and then he
just be smiling he behind he some people
think it's hilarious when people get
sick he's gone
he's gotta get a good man but he got a
little scare so that so then it we go to
it's bland and blue back up go to land
loop back up [ __ ] this is after four
hours of [ __ ] flying yeah uh ladies
and gentleman we've tried landing twice
now we're low on fuel so we're gonna
have to stop in Las Vegas Nevada
detour and I'm like oh my job when you
went you went what the [ __ ] yow spits
man we're on our way there and then this
guy next to me the only reason why I
didn't throw up or freaked out I told
Brian about to freak out about to get
arrested on the flight like Paris
Hilton's brother I'm gonna freak the
[ __ ] out man and the guy next to me goes
he goes what are you doing in Vegas
I literally my head was like this huh
I'm in a horrible mood yes what brings
you to Vegas like well yeah no one's
headed to Vegas all right no one
purposely headed to Vegas and he goes
and I told Brian this weekend that stop
laughing he goes ah after a day like
this nothing like a good steak and a
dick suck a good old steak in of dicks
nothin like a good ol snake in a dick
sighs he was not attractive I was like
that poor girl
that poor steak ate God what brings you
to Vegas my head well he is well well
nothing no one no fuel no one will you
want to be here no if you want stormy
gives me sir no one planned for this is
I'm happy about it nothing better than a
good dick suck in a Stace taking a dick
suck hey excuse me sir element that does
sound nice though a nice t-bone a dick
suck how aggressive is that well older
man then no one at home we're the best
a word the entire flight this goes I'm
not mad at it all I had the image I had
was just him in a hammock with it with
steak breath and his belly and she's
sitting on the edge of his hotel bedroom
just and just with some poor soul just
gobbling his weenus small rod yeah Oh
God and I got a pop an antacid keep
going you can do good but it wouldn't be
a good dish
maybe it'd be this oh it would be this
tough tough and she's good
sorry I got a big old brush I'm gonna
sleep in it doesn't allow for much to
come out God think of a fat bastard from
Austin Powers you know speaking of a
nice you know speaking of a grenade is
Harry peak that's taking a nice steak
and a dicksuck excuse me sir that's very
aggressive does sound nice though steak
of a dick suck that add a SDK or was
that sound like a movie an action movie
steak and it does like a bad Hornet
Russell steak in a dick steak store
JT gibbler's a dick sucked I wonder if
you you gets taken the dicks out if you
say it quickly it almost sounds like
like a hero's name oh my god is that
sticking a dick sign or what do you
think you guys that steaks taking the
dicks huh or what do you think of the
next meeting big meeting we have through
my suits
any ideas where yeah yeah I love still
unique so stay my dicks out and you know
that that restaurant that Asian
restaurants taking a dick suck all right
steak my dick sucked
oh I'll make reservations it'd be nice
to go stay in dick stuck oh that's a
great name for a dog it's taking a
dicksuck steak my dick suck dicks I know
gret whole aggressive is that this guy
was just maybe he's just over flying
everything inside no and didn't hide it
nothing is like well that's his thing
tell you I could use a steak in a
dicksuck yeah that's something he thinks
about all the time like that when he's
at work and he hates he's fixing big
machinery they fly him in to fix some
big hydraulic machine big old Digby he's
just like sitting there yeah he's just
working out of machines I can get this
out get this grease off my hands I can't
wait for a steak and a dick suck a guy
like that probably I've been a lot of
north I like that I'm assuming likes
like small Asian women and a big old rib
ah see I'm gonna go I'm gonna go even
deeper I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
girls no I'm gonna say probably a big
black girl now I think I see huh what
about a big black girl a nice ribbon
nope see I absolutely 100% think he
likes a skinny Filipino boy of about 18
years old just legal just because he
doesn't like getting trouble and then he
likes to pay him to slap him around a
little bit too I know what kind of state
goes with that I put your pants down and
take my belts here State goes with that
maybe big old Kansas City yeah Kansas
City State I can't say snake it myself
oh yeah connection a Filipino boy
something smooth I don't get not be from
Burma could be from Sri Lanka anybody's
brown smooth with a full mouth that's
what I'm looking Filipino boys and a
nice tomahawk steak Tom my shape to save
his cubes down I don't like any pubes
and get them or get somewhere my mouth
I'm I'm taking it all to his backside I
disagree I don't think he's gay that guy
was no no that's the old man that's not
gay I think I think he like like just
like a small girl and a nice runaway a
nice New York Strip yeah those guys look
they they they come the bus stops for
Runaways yeah you wanna make some extra
money
mmm he's looking for one of those lot
lizards down on their luck yeah he's
looking for one of them nightwalkers
down on their luck run away with it was
nice little looser lon t-shirt and
doesn't even [ __ ] where it comes from
he'd get it from Denny's wherever yes
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]